تبذل اخر الجهود للتوصل الى تسويه تغني عن
عمليه بريه تركيه جديده ضد ما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه تجدد تركيا تهديدها
ومطالبها وتشير الى ان العمليه البريه في
الشمال السوري يمكن ان تبدا في اي وقت
تكشف وسائل اعلام المقربه من النظام
السوري على اللقاء في شمال سوريا جمع قائد
القوات الروسيه في سوريا اليكساندر شايكو
بالقائد فيما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مصدومه عبدي وتتحدث عن تقديم
عرضا بان تحل قوات النظام السوري محل
القوات الكرديه لا يعرف ما هو موقف ما
يسمى بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من العرض
الروسي كما لم تعلن واشنطن التي تعد
الحديث الرئيسيه لما يسمى بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه حتى الان موقفها من المطالب
بالتركيه قال جون كيري منسقه الاتصالات في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي ان من حق
تركيا
بالارهاب عن نفسها لكنه اوضح في الوقت
نفسه ان واشنطن ليست مع اي اعمال قد تؤدي
الى وقوع ضحايا او تدر بجهودها لمواصله
العمل مع شركائها السوريين ضد تنظيم
الدوله
الشركاء السوريون الذين يتحدث عنهم كربي
ومقاتلوا ما يعرف بوحداث حمايه الشعب
الكرديه الذين تعتبرهم تركيا حليفه
الامريكيين في النيتو ارهابيين في اجتماع
وزراء خارجيه الناتو ببخار سيكون موضوع
الوضع في شمال سوريا حاضرا بابعاده
المختلفه ستناقش الحمله البريه التركيه
المحتمله والدعم الذي تقول تركيا ان كندا
والسويد الراغبتين في الانضمام
تقدمانه لحزب العمال الكردستاني والذي
بسبب به كم توافق على انضمامهما بعد قال
وزير خارج تركيا مولود شوشو اوغلو ان تقدم
من تحقق بشان الدعم الذي تقدمه السويد وفي
لندن لحزب العمال الكردستاني مشيرا الى
ضروره اتخاذ اضافيه خصوصا من طرف السويد
تطورات كانت حاضره في مجلس الامن الدولي
حيث حضر المبعوث الاموي الخاص الى سوريا
من وجود عناصر 90 خطير في شمال سوريا يمكن
ايه يهدد الاستقرار الاقليمي